Russia fired at least
60 missiles into Ukraine overnight,
especially in
and around the beleaguered
eastern city of back loot.
That's according
to the Ukrainian military.
And further
south, an onslaught of drone attacks.
CNN's Nick Paton
Walsh is in southeastern
Ukraine where he and his team
narrowly escaped a missile strike.
To bring you this report,
close
to Ukraine's
imminent counter
offensive in the southeast,
where Russia has long been brutalizing
pain is commonplace and the damage often
everywhere and indiscriminate.
The quiet is a blessing that rarely lasts
We're warned of a missile strike
in coming and leave
We can feel the pressure.
We can you me
not just behind our armored cars
right behind us.
Now, can you hear me?
John,
our producer, is in our second
vehicle, just passed the smoke
joint, Igor McGlinchey,
and isn't concerned that can you hear me?
The missile landed
right between our cars.
Not. Can you hear me
now?
Can you hear me in 10 seconds?
We have no idea.
If they are overcautious.
You just said something, not.
Can you hear me?
Yes, I can hear you.
That's them.
Are you guys okay?
We're fine. Just leave.
Drive out the way we left.
We leave together for so many.
That choice of leaving
is something imaginary
that happens above ground.
The only power and water in town
down here were life underground.
Here has been hard for quite some time,
but it will get harder
when the counteroffensive begins pushing,
certainly in this direction.
If there is space for laughter,
it's from this.
A screechy,
slapstick, Soviet
era comedy about a drunken goofball.
Briefly, bending the thick
set grimaces here.
New moon is sparkling ultra
so that
would be someone with a primitive
social cohesion
when it was on the side of the moon.
He has come to the show
which is led the gypsy
king to evoke the emotion.
No matter where you see his horse.
But then she will respond.
Jimmy Carter in this forbidding
riot gear, since I'm delivering you
here, a few
guardian angels seem here to flit by
in a town
where 50 died in the war
and 200 were injured.
Safety is just a word here,
and rubble is a place
Now, Jake,
that town of Arrakis
is pretty close
to the front lines, essentially.
And today
the locals told us they had small arms
fire on its outskirts.
Essentially,
they think
Russian troops
probing towards Ukrainian positions
as Ukraine seems to be mounting forces
for a counteroffensive.
Long awaited long
Ukraine,
so long, NATO's supplied
and bolstered and planned.
And so I think there are concerns here
that the bombardment
you saw there,
which we briefly experienced,
which locals have been enduring
for months, may intensify
as that potential move by Ukraine
pushes forwards Jake.
All right. Nick Paton Walsh,
so glad you and your team are okay.
And Zakariya, appreciate it.
Back on Capitol
Hill, House lawmakers
heard from victims of Russia's wartime
atrocities as.
Take a listen to this.
57 year old Ukrainian woman from her son
speaking through a translator
for the men.
In January of this year.
They came for me.
All right.
And then they took me
to their torture chamber
and kept me there. For five days.
They forced me to undress,
but them cutting my body with a knife
and threatening to rape and kill me,
who also forced me to dig my own grave.
Just one of so many stories like that.
Joining us now, Ukraine's
prosecutor General Andre Cost.
And so good to have you here,
prosecutor general.
So we just heard one of the 80,000
reported war crimes
by your officers count,
including torture,
murder, rape,
the forced deportation
of so many Ukrainian children to Russia.
You said today
you finished cases about half of the 310
perpetrators of the crimes.
Unfortunately we're hearing about
new cases every day.
You know
CNN has
has teams on the ground in Ukraine.
How do you even keep
up with the caseload?
Of course we
prioritize our work
and for us, the priority are cases
where people civilians
were killed, injured
or ill treated in different manner.
When they have been victims of harm,
sexual and any other type of attack
and prioritize these cases.
Of course,
we the most challenging for us
is to identify the perpetrator
because many of them
are hiding their faces But for cases
we have already finished,
we not only identified the perpetrators,
but we also collected evidence
that they initially committed
these war crimes.
And hundreds
and thousands of cases are ongoing.
And this is our primary job
to deliver justice to Ukrainians
in our national system
while we have already great results
in international level. Right.
So you met with U.S.
Attorney General Merrick
Garland on Monday of this week,
and he announced the U.S.
Justice Department
would detail a prosecutor to The Hague
to assist you
in investigating these Russian war crimes
in Ukraine.
What else do you need
from the United States, your office?
We have a unique
cooperation with the Office of Attorney
Merrick Garland,
and the deployment of the prosecutor
to the International Center
for the Prosecution
of the Crime of Aggression
into The Hague,
who will work
shoulder to shoulder
with Ukrainian and other
international prosecutors.
Is a clear
sign, a clear example of our support
with regard
to making the highest Russian political
and military leadership accountable
for the crime of aggression,
the leadership crime?
Because if crime of aggression
would not have been committed,
there would be no 80,000 incidents
of other war crimes.
So there's a warrant out
for Putin's arrest
for the deportation
of the Ukrainian children.
Do you think he will ever face
any accountability?
We all know that he will face
accountability.
We will do anything possible.
And our task as a lawyers
is to prepare everything,
to prepare cases,
to collect evidence
and to prepare our legal framework.
It's not our we have no time actually
to think about the future,
whether we will capture him or not.
But I will
give you an example
of our senior advisers
from all over the world
who started as young prosecutors
in cases in tribunals for future
war criminals, in, uh, in the conflicts
of former Yugoslavia territories.
They never imagined that people
like Milosevic and Karadzic
would be in the dock
of international tribunals
when they started their work.
But at the end of the day,
both of them were tried and prosecuted.
So our aim together
with the International Criminal Court
is to go to go ahead
not only against Putin,
but also against other
high ranking officials
who are
who are responsible
for the thousands of war crimes
committed in Ukraine.
I want to turn to Ukraine's
current battlefield needs.
I spoke with the UK defense minister,
Ben Wallace, Here's
a little bit of what he told me
Does Ukraine
have what
it needs for the counteroffensive?
And why isn't the UK providing
Ukraine with typhoon jets right now
as they've requested?
Well, I think, first of all,
Ukraine is getting ready
and is receiving
the supplies that it needs,
whether that is artillery shells
or whether that is specialist
anti-air equipment.
The huge amount has been donated
over the last year,
and that is building to a
significant capability.
He says Ukraine is receiving
the supplies that it needs.
Are you receiving everything you need?
I don't think that anyone in Ukraine
can say
that we receive everything we need.
We understand that we need more
and we need it quicker in order to
liberate our territory
as soon as possible
because it will save lives of our people.
Because every day more people are killed
and not only actually
we're talking about civilians,
let's also think about our servicemen
because they are protecting our country.
They are defending our country. But
they are
victims of
the crime of aggression
committed by Russian Federation.
And as quick as we liberate
our territory, more lives will be saved,
not only civilians, but servicemen,
because many of these servicemen,
they are civilians yesterday. Right.
And it's about their families.
And their lives.
So we are grateful for any assistance
we have.
But I think that we
need more and quicker.